another report for the daily wire I
think is important in one generation the
world has experienced seismic shifts in
the way we communicate and relate to one
another but these changes are coming at
a high cost particularly to our children
uh most teenagers 97 report being online
every day and nearly half say they're
online almost constantly but Recent
research from scientists at the
University of North Carolina shows that
all of this time on social media is
linked to changes in the teen brain by
looking at brain scans of middle
schoolers between the ages of 12 and 15
neuroscientists at UNC found that
frequent social media users at age 12
showed heightened sensitivity to social
rewards from peers over time teenagers
who were less engaged with social media
at age 12 showed less interest in Social
rewards over time
Gene twang a psychology professor at San
Diego State University and author of
igen has also sounded the alarm on the
link between social media use and
anxiety and depression in teens there's
a substantial link to depression and
that link tends to be stronger among
girls the more time the teen
particularly a teen girl spends using
social media the more likely it is that
she'll be depressed according to twang
any new habit or learned behavior leaves
its imprint on the brain the fact that
the brain is imprinted by social media
use should not come as a surprise but
most parents who let their children
create social media accounts are
probably unaware of the extent to which
these social media accounts are training
their children to seek peer approval or
what the long-term consequences may be
um so this is
just the latest bit of scientific
evidence
that it is not good for children for
them to sit around all day staring at
their phones remember 50 and I think the
numbers probably low but according to
the latest data latest surveys 50 of
teens and adolescents say that they're
online constantly
and by constantly and anyone who's ever
been around a kid in this category knows
that constantly really means constantly
like they're never not they sleep and
then they wake up and they're staring at
the phone the entire day no matter what
else they're doing they have the phone
and they're looking at their phone
um I don't think we need
we certainly
have have never needed to wait around
for scientific evidence that this is not
a healthy way to live
and I don't need I don't need any
scientific analysis or any study to tell
me this is not a healthy way for kids to
live
the only the only thing science will do
is tell us in precisely what sort of
ways it is unhealthy so we know that
it's extremely unhealthy
and we can figure out a lot of the ways
that it's not healthy
um driving the Obesity epidemic is one
thing
that's the least of it
but then science I suppose can come back
around and get a little bit more
specific give us some of the details
none of these details are surprising
this is not this is not a
hey it's it's not even a human existence
the human beings we're not meant to live
this way
and whenever we can look at the way that
we're living our lives right now
you know this is this part of learning
from history and learning from our
ancestors and I know people these days
they want to pretend that our ancestors
and uh have nothing to teach us and
nothing to tell tell us we want to sever
ourselves come entirely from our
ancestors
um not listen to the testimony of those
who came before us but that's a very
foolish way to live and if you were to
listen to them then you know you should
look at the way you're living and and um
you could ask yourself like what what is
it about Modern Life that would be
entirely foreign
to our ancestors
and just because it'd be entirely
foreign to our ancestors doesn't mean
that it's necessarily wrong there's a
lot of modern medicine at least the
legitimate parts of it that would have
been foreign our ancestors
antibiotics would have been formed
doesn't mean that we shouldn't take them
but
having a little device
that you carry around all the time
and having your entire life center
around this device that is one of those
things that is unprecedented in history
that there's no analog for it
many of the things that we think are
unprecedented in modern history when you
look at it you see that well this is
just a version of something that existed
before nothing new Under the Sun as it
says as we say actually there are some
things that are new Unto the Sun
smartphones on the internet are new
Under the Sun there is no analog for it
nothing comparable to it historically
this is an entirely new thing
it might be one of the only entirely new
things
and so this is entirely new thing that
we have decided to completely structure
our lives around
that in and of itself doesn't make it
wrong but it is a reason to examine it
and say hmm no one's ever lived this way
before is
are we on yeah we are we are verging off
a completely different path
is this the right thing to do
I think in this case it's obviously not
and clearly when your kids grow up on
this stuff and all they ever do is is
use the internet and their whole life is
structured around it
as they found in the study I mean among
other things makes them a lot more
susceptible to peer pressure a lot more
susceptible to influence uh much more
desperate for approval and affirmation
kids already are inclined in that way
they they need approval any affirmation
that's not that's not an unhealthy
desire for a child
but for kids that are on social media
this is their entire life
you gotta I mean you you just you ha I
could
keep saying it a million times over and
I will continue to say it you have to
rescue your children from this you just
must you can't you cannot you must force
your your children to have real
childhoods and to live real human lives
you know
um and they're they're not gonna like it
if you've allowed them to use the phone
up until now and you take that stuff
away and if you allow them to play video
games six hours a day and you take that
away they're not gonna like it at first
it's it's they're going to react like a
heroin addict when you take the heroin
needle away but but it's for their own
good
foreign
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]